hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen zu unserem ersten video aus
vietnam
unser thema ist heute haben oder sein
haben und sein sind zwei hilfs werben im
deutschen und wenn ihr schon das perfekt
im deutschen gelernt habt dann wisst ihr
das perfekt bildet sich aus einem
hilfswerk und einem partie zieht zum
beispiel ich lese ich habe gelesen ich
gehe ich bin gegangen
die frage ist jetzt welches hilfswerk
benutzt man haben oder sein
in den meisten fällen lässt sich die
frage relativ einfach beantworten
trotzdem haben viele leute damit immer
noch probleme
und zwar sowohl anfänger als auch
fortgeschrittene
deshalb haben wir heute eine kleine
übung für euch wir fangen an mit der
grundregel die grundregel ist
ich benutze immer haben außer bei
bewegungs werben und zwar vor allem
bewegungs werben wo sich mit der
bewegung einen ort oder ein zustand
verändert
zum beispiel ich bin eingestiegen
vorher war ich draußen jetzt bin ich
drinnen ich habe den ort bzw einen
zustand verändert das ganze üben wir
jetzt und zwar haben wir ein kleines
video für euch vorbereitet wir erzählen
euch jetzt unsere reise von berlin nach
hanoi und das ganze im perfekt mit
kurzen sätzen und vielen werben rund um
die bewegung und ihr könnt selber mal
hören und sehen wann benutzen wir was
haben oder sein
los geht's
am sonntag sind wir früh aufgestanden
dann haben wir uns fertig gemacht
wir haben unsere koffer gepackt um 7 uhr
haben wir die wohnung verlassen und sind
zum flughafen gefahren
wir sind in die u bahn eingestiegen
mit der u-bahn sind wir zum
alexanderplatz gefahren
dort haben wir den regionalzug zum
flughafen genommen
im sonnenaufgang sind wir am flughafen
angekommen
wir haben unseren check-in-schalter
gesucht
dann haben wir auf unseren flug nach
moskau gewartet um 39 hat das boarding
begonnen
um 10 uhr haben wir berlin verlassen
wir sind mit ihrem flott geflogen
janisch hat wie immer angst gehabt beim
fliegen
zwei stunden später sind wir in moskau
gelandet
am flughafen in moskau haben wir fünf
stunden verbracht wir haben kaffee
getrunken gearbeitet und gitarre
gespielt dann haben wir uns um das
nächste flugzeug gesetzt
der flug von moskau nach hanoi hat neun
stunden gedauert
wir haben die ganze nacht filme geguckt
um 6 uhr ist die sonne aufgegangen
wir sind einmal um die halbe welt
geflogen um 9 uhr sind wir in vietnam
gelandet beim landen haben alle
geklatscht
ich habe diese tradition noch nie
verstanden
[Musik]
am flughafen sind wir als erstes zur
einreisekontrolle gegangen
hier haben wir einen stempel bekommen
[Musik]
an der gepäckausgabe haben wir unsere
koffer abgeholt
[Musik]
draußen hat janisch kurz gejubelt weil
er den flug überlebt hat
[Musik]
am flughafen hat uns ein mann abgeholt
der uns zu unserem hotel gebracht hat
[Musik]
nach 40 minuten sind wir in unserem
hotel angekommen
wir haben direkt einen kleinen
spaziergang gemacht
wir sind durch die straßen von hanoi
gegangen
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir endlich angekommen
hallo und liebe grüße das war unsere
reise geschichte von berlin nach hanoi
wir hoffen ihr konntet ein bisschen
hören und sehen wann wir haben und sein
benutzen
und jetzt sprechen wir noch über eine
ausnahme es gibt drei ausnahmen bei
denen auch sein genutzt wird und dass es
sein werden und bleiben das heißt bei
diesen werben muss ich nicht unbedingt
etwas verändern oder eine bewegung von
einem ort einem anderen ort stattfinden
und man benutzt trotzdem sein
hier kommen ein paar beispiele ich bin
in die stadt gegangen eine bewegung ich
habe den ort geändert
ich bin in der stadt gewesen ist nicht
unbedingt eine bewegung
man kann sagen man ist an einem ort
gewesen aber man benutzt trotzdem sein
ich bin in der stadt geblieben
auch nicht unbedingt ein ortswechsel
aber beim nutzt man benutzt sein und ich
bin mutter geworden das ist eine status
veränderung tatsächlich hier benutzt man
auch sein
das waren die ausnahmen wir hoffen euch
hat das video gefallen und wenn dir noch
weiter üben wollt dann könnt ihr gerne
bei uns ein päckchen werden und übungen
machen zu haben welches sein
das ganze geht hier wenn er ein mitglied
bei uns werdet und wenn die asse
chairman abonnieren möchte freuen wir
uns sehr
das könnt ihr hier machen wir gehen
jetzt los wir erkunden hanoi und wir
freuen uns euch auch am sonntag wieder
begrüßen zu dürfen dann mit interviews
auf der straße mit menschen die in hanoi
deutsch sprechen und lernen
bis bald